à chaque fois que tu demandes des
américains tenait tu vois tu es encore
plus confus jandoubi me disent toujours
in the way parce qu'ils savent pas tu
connais ces gens qui peuvent expliquer
comment sa maison était avant incroyable
qu'on appelait là c'est la cuisine et l
autre côté c'est fou non non j'ai pu
avoir un passeport canadien
j'ai aussi un passeport marocain nous
amis aussi je n'utilise pas pour des
raisons évidentes c'est pas le moment en
ce moment d'arriver aux états unis à la
douane avec un grand passeport vert
écrit avec des grandes lettres en arabe
doré et dire je suis un comique
j'ai textile vie je dis que tu veux
faire demain soir bien on va boire un
verre m'a dit pas de problème
danseuse espagnole danseuse espagnole de
feu d'artifice quatre verres de
champagne un singe qui se couvraient le
visage une paire de talons rouges du
vergne en deux buildings un taxi et une
aubergine j'avais pas quoi faire je n'ai
envoyé une ambulance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]